ils sont déjà aussi en train de se
pencher juste après sur le couronnement
du roi Charleroi tu vas faire exactement
le même raz-de-marée
qu'est-ce que vous diriez à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon soir oh je n'ai rien à dire à
Monsieur mélangeant il y a tellement
d'autres personnes à qui je voudrais
parler dans la chambre de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
de la reine encore pendant 10 jours
Jean-Luc qu'est-ce que vous vouliez dire
vous diriez quoi moi personnellement
voilà peut-être que j'ai un peu plus
d'éducation que certaines autres
personnes mais en tout cas voilà je suis
un peu choqué par en voilà un manque de
dignité je voudrais simplement qu'on
reconnaisse qu'on enterre quelqu'un qui
était pas comme les espèces on
reconnaisse quand même hein
[Rires]
merci Antoine député une pièce de
l'Essonne d'être avec nous est-ce que
vous soutenez les propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je pense qu'il a dit un peu ce
que tout le monde pensait c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs on est en train d'en bouffer
de la reine d'Angleterre depuis
plusieurs jours donc voilà Jean-Luc moi
vous savez quand on est venu dans le
taxi vous m'avez envoyé on parlait de
l'émission Bon alors qu'est-ce qu'on dit
machin le chauffeur de taxi nous a dit
ah c'est vrai vous avez raison on en a
marre de bouffer
c'est ce que je disais un effet de
saturation médiatique sur ce sujet alors
que il y a d'autres sujets qui sont
hyper importants je vous en prends par
exemple pour en prendre qu'un il y a
quatre personnes qui sont mortes
d'accident du travail dans les deux
derniers jours où est-ce qu'on en parle
nulle part nulle part
donc c'est tellement choquant ce que
vous dites mais parce que la reine mais
parce que la reine d'Angleterre c'est 70
ans de Rennes parce que la reine
d'Angleterre dans le monde parce que la
reine d'Angleterre
parce que la reine d'Angleterre voilà
était aimé comme personne était aimé
c'était une femme exceptionnelle et
parce que en trois vies elle a une
destinée que [ __ ] mais Monsieur
Mélenchon n'aura jamais voilà Monsieur
alors un petit peu de respect parce que
quelqu'un est ouvrier agricole de 36 ans
et qui meurt le la main broyée dans une
arracheuse de palette
avec la vidéo
monsieur mais quel rapport
c'est ça que j'essaie de vous dire c'est
que il y a des sujets qui sont toujours
posé dans la scène médiatique et la
reine d'Angleterre très bien mais on est
tous attaché à à Elisabeth II parce
qu'on a tous grandi avec elle moi aussi
ça faisait déjà plusieurs
on a grandi avec elle avec ses chapeaux
par exemple et c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça que sa mort c'est pour ça que ça mord
est un événement qui court mais
néanmoins néanmoins néanmoins on peut se
poser la question et particulièrement
dans un pays comme la France qui est un
pays qui a mis à bas les rois et a mis
en place la République posé la question
de faire une telle place et vous qui
vous posez la question
est-ce que tu veux répondre à Monsieur
Léo monsieur le député moi je n'ai rien
à dire parce que tu es venu être mort je
sais plus
je peux vous dire c'est que
vous voyez ça fait descendre la pression
j'ai été heurté par le terme par le
verbe bouffer moi avant hier soir bah
bouffer des coudre vénère bah je savais
même pas comment on les conjugué parce
que la vulgarité ça fait pas vraiment
partie de moi et je pense qu'il a toute
une grosse une excitation
populaire on dit quand il y a un
événement comme ça on dit ah là là oui
on va en bouffer oui
très précisément très précisément c'est
sûr je vous dis c'est que pour la
personne pas de problème tout le monde
est triste et tout le monde avait
quelque chose d'Elizabeth de en lui
puisque nous avons et je le répète
grandit avec grandit avec elle mais
néanmoins pour la couronne jamais pour
la couronne pas de tristesse parce que
toute monarchie est un abus de pouvoir
et ça justement mais quand on est en
tournage mais si toute monarchie est un
abus de pouvoir parce qu'une monarchie
proclame une monarchie proclame le fait
qu'une personne et qu'une lignée est
supérieure au reste des êtres humains
elle ne gouverne pas mais elle proclame
quoi quand même ils ont 26
parlementaires il y a
il va ramasser 28 milliards il va
ramasser 28 milliards d'euros de
patrimoine alors justement
pour 6000 € d'alloc
que sur Amazon 28 milliards d'euros
chaque personne
croyons on a pas ces montants là il est
impossible de chiffrer vraiment la
fortune des meilleurs
c'est pas ce qui est bien arrivé comment
est-ce que vous pouvez avancer ce monde
alors on va faire
c'est à dire s'il vous plaît
pas à m'exprimer
non mais quand je te dis stop c'est stop
sinon tu vas retrouver la reine
puisqu'on parlait d'Angleterre on
voulait revenir sur cette vidéo du
nouveau roi Charles III qui fait
polémique alors qu'il signe un livre
d'or en Irlande du Nord l'encre du
styloie coulait sur sa main ça l'a
vénère de ouf il avait l'air vénère
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà justement pourquoi justement c'est
pas la monarchie d'Angleterre qu'on a
mais c'était la reine d'Angleterre qui
elle effectivement était une femme
parfaite jamais un mot plus haut que
l'autre elle ne s'exprimait jamais
personne n'a même plus c'est pour ou
contre le brexit personne même dans sa
famille c'est une femme exceptionnelle
elle avait un agenda qui était heure par
heure sur bouquet déjà sur un an elle
est rencontrée tout le monde elle a fait
beaucoup beaucoup pour la paix en Europe
et personne le sait à ce point-là lui en
revanche j'ai plus de doutes et là on
montre un exemple de son fils qui est
effectivement et déjà beaucoup plus
discutable et là on pourra voilà c'est
on sort d'ici mais la Reine d'Angleterre
non et c'est pour ça que j'aurais aimé
que Monsieur Mélenchon qui était quand
même un homme d'État et un tout petit
peu de dignité pour cette femme qui a
fait 70 ans de règne à deux ans près
battait Louis XIV
non mais qu'il est un peu
[Applaudissements]
j'aime de l'hymne là alors respectez-la
un petit peu évidemment
il y avait aujourd'hui 8 km 8 km
6h d'attendre des gens du monde entier
quelques secondes quelques secondes
aujourd'hui c'est tout le monde si on
fait 8 semaines
vous avez regardé aussi les les les le
reportage de BFM TV qui a interrogé des
gens des classes populaires justement
sur le le l'enterrement de la reine et
les cérémonies qui sont autour qui
disent que on pourrait peut-être parler
d'autre chose eux aussi en Angleterre
donc non tout le monde c'est vrai il y a
plein de gens qui aiment Elisabeth II il
y a pas de souci sur le sujet est-ce que
vous dites sur ce qu'elle a fait très
bien très intéressant on pourrait aussi
parler du Bloody Sunday quand même parce
que c'était quand même la reine c'était
quand même la monarchie qui s'est battu
contre la l'Irlande qui voulait devenir
républicaine donc non la monarchie n'est
pas exemple de tout problème y compris
la monarchie britannique et y compris
sous le règne d'Élisabeth II mais bon
alors oui mais quand même
juste qu'on revoit
c'est c'est la file d'attente
plus de 6 heures d'attente
mais cette file d'attente qui était déjà
impressionnante et qui ne cesse de
grossir pour pouvoir avoir le fameux
bracelet qui autorise à accéder à
Westminster Hall et à la dépouille de la
Reine Elizabeth oui et pour certains il
faudra attendre demain voir après demain
les gens donc vont dormir là-bas
ils attendent des heures et des heures
pour l'avoir juste on entre un tout
petit peu et on la salue juste quelques
secondes voilà juste comme ça très
rapidement moi j'appelle ça du fanatisme
moi j'appelle ça limite du fanatisme je
suis désolé ils vont attendre
vous vous rendez compte de de la
situation et ensuite donc Charles III je
suis content que vous ayez montrer les
images parce que c'est une forme de
mépris de mépris total pour les gens qui
travaillent pour lui
de ce qui s'est passé une perquisition
dans laquelle on a envoyé
monsieur dans cette histoire
vous savez pourquoi un policier vous
savez moi ce que pourquoi j'ai été payé
perquisitionné et 1366 €, on m'accuse de
détournement de fonds publics voilà
pourquoi on va perquisitionner parce que
je suis un militant politique et que
bien sûr oui précisément vous avez 100
personnes qui sont allés perquisitionner
Jean-Luc Mélenchon moi j'aimerais bien
qu'ils aillent courir après les
fraudeurs et les évadés fiscaux tiens
qu'on les envoie les les les les
responsable non mais les 100 policiers
qui est de l'oclifs qui ont la
répartition précisément ils sont
responsables de la lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale qui fasse
leur travail c'est la reine qu'ils
aillent chercher les 80 milliards
d'euros des gens qui sont les nouveaux
privilégiés de notre époque en fait vous
vous servez de la reine juste en fait
pour venir ici c'est déballer votre
discours effectivement
vous sortez tout le programme de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous voulez qu'on
parle de la République vous voulez qu'on
parle de la République la Première
République je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure sera pas le 21 septembre
et vous savez première République on
devrait la fêter parce qu'elle a pour
elle un certain nombre de choses qu'il a
sont extrêmement positives
mais justement quel rapport avec la
reine nous nous sommes débarrassés du
roi à la fin et nous l'avons déposé nous
l'avons déposé le 18 le 21 non le 21 le
effectivement Cyril mais je suis content
de vous en parler parce qu'il en reste
un il reste le président de la
République est une sorte de monarque
présidentielle et que nous pourrions lui
aussi dégager avec une sixième
république vous savez le jour où le jour
où la reine le jour où il a dit ça on a
compris monsieur on a compris le jour il
a dit ça on va bouffer de la reine on a
compris pardon et tous les Français que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'avait pas la statue
d'un homme d'État
personne
du peuple c'est précisé
[Musique]